[MUSIC]
Hi, hello everyone,
my name is Colin.
I have the foolish ambition
of trying to get through two
projects in ten minutes
right after lunch.
So hopefully,
this will wake you all up.
The first project is what
we call Project Karya.
Karya means work in Hindi.
And the goal of Project Karya
is to provide dignified digital
labor.
I think most of you in
the audience probably know about
this notion of crowdsourcing.
So the basic idea behind
crowdsourcing is that we're
going to take a large
scale digital task.
Preferably digital
tasks that are hard for
our computers to automate.
And we're going to chop these
tasks into millions of little
pieces, what we
called microwork.
Then we're going to give this
microwork to humans, to people,
to accomplish.
And then we're going to collect
the results at the end,
that's the basic idea.
Now what's unique about Project
Karya is the demographic of
workers that we're targeting.
So the typical crowdsourcing
worker today is college
educated, feels relatively
comfortable with spoken and
written English, and
often has access to a laptop or
a desktop computer.
Now the population that we're
targeting here are rural
Indians.
Typically low income, people who
may not have any of those three
traits that I've mentioned.
So, our goal with Project Karya
is to provide employment
opportunities for these people.
And as much as that,
we're also trying to
help them build a set of digital
skills, IT skills for example.
So that they can build a resume
over time and hopefully get
a job of their own once
they're done with our project.
And all the while of course,
we're trying to accomplish
useful tasks and
collect useful data.
So you can think of Project
Karya as much as a social
welfare program, as it is
a crowdsourcing platform.
In fact in the long term,
we're hoping to partner
with the Indian government
to help scale this up as
a social welfare program.
The technology we have,
here we have a server
that takes in some task, like
a pile of handwritten forms.
And then chops that task into
individual pieces of microwork,
like pictures of individual
words in that form.
And then hands it out to
an Android application
that workers can use to
accomplish those tasks,
gain skills, earn money, etc.
And then we collect all of
the results at the end.
The range of task that we're
targeting is fairly broad.
We're looking at
image classification,
formed digitization translation,
even tasks like GeoTagging.
So going out with your phone and
taking pictures of things or
even taking sensor measurements,
maybe taking soil
measurements in rural areas.
We've been working in
earnest on this project for
about six months.
There is a beautiful photo
of rural Maharashtra
that Manu Jopra took, Manu is
kind of leading this project.
So far we've done initial user
study in partnership with
IAT Bombay.
And we're dealing with
a Adivasi community in rural
Maharashtra like I mentioned.
Most of the users here actually
they have never actually used
a smart phone before.
So the task that we gave
them was actually fairly
straightforward, which is on
the smartphone use a Marathi
keyboard to enter their name.
And the results were
pretty promising.
There's a nice picture,
you can see our first
user of Project Karya.
So there's a lot of things that
we've learned in the last six
months, both in talking to
government agencies and
doing these user studies.
I'm just gonna focus on one
of the challenges that we've
encountered which is
a very basic problem.
These people do not
make very much money,
they cannot afford very
much cellular data.
So even if they're NGOs or
public service announcers or
even for profit content
providers that want to give
content for
free to these people,
they can do so because the users
have to pay for the data,
they can't afford data
download in the first place.
So that brings me to
my next set of slides.
Wait, the next project we
call people powered bulk
data networking.
There have been a lot of project
proposals in the past for
how to get Internet to
the rest of the world.
SpaceX in thinking about
low Earth orbit satellites,
Facebook is thinking
about these big drones,
Google is thinking
about these balloons.
And what most of these projects
don't really understand is how
people already make use of the
Internet today in a place rural
Bihar.
What these companies
like Google and
Facebook are not realizing
is that, people have already
figured out how to get their
hands on Internet content
even if they can't afford
the Internet access.
Namely, there
are these apps that
people use to transfer
files between phones.
So one of the phones
turns on a hotspot,
the other phone connects
to the hotspot,
you can transfer files at
very fast rates, okay?
So this is really popular, this
is actually all over the world,
not just India.
The most popular of these
apps is called SHAREit, and
they claim to have 200 million
users in India alone, so
this is a massive thing.
And before that,
before smartphones,
there is of course Bluetooth,
people have been doing this for
a long time.
Now the way that this
is done today is,
unfortunately still quite
limited, its quite ad hoc.
And one of the biggest
limitations is that, I typically
only share with people that
I know, so I have to go and
talk to you and say, do you
have this movie that I want,
I have this file,
should we share?
I can't show it people like you
in this room where with in Wi-Fi
range, we could be transferring
files right now but
I don't have any content
discovering mechanism.
So the basic research question
we're asking here is,
if we provide some services
like content discovery,
can we change people's behavior,
can we unable people to start
sharing between people who
have never met each other?
Let's start sharing in this
room because we have files that
other people want.
So what we have is pretty
straightforward that we just
have some like cloud service,
That runs
say in a South Indian
data center.
And a content provider,
like I don't know some NGO,
has some video they want
to distribute some people.
They give us a copy
of that file and
we extract some metadata
from that file.
And then we run an Android app
on people's smartphones and
this android app automatically
detects if I have some of
the files that the content
providers have given us.
Without actually having
to download all the data,
it's just using metadata
like a hash of the content.
And the other thing this app
does is it automatically detects
if I'm within Wi-Fi
range about 80
meters of someone else who has a
file that I want or vice versa,
it will automatically
turn on the Wi-Fi and
automatically perform
that transfer.
Now one other cool feature is
that if the NGO or the content
provider wants to incentivize
people to spread this kind of
in a viral way, they might
even be willing to give money.
I'm not gonna be able
to draw a rupee symbol,
excuse me,
I'll draw a dollar sign instead.
So if they want to incentivize
someone to spread this virally,
the person who has the content
that's spreading it to the other
person, they will
receive a mobile top up.
This is like a form of
cellular data basically.
So the idea here is that we can
make this spread virally by
having them take the effort to
go walk to the next village and
earn some mobile top ups by
giving it to other people, okay?
Now from the users perspective,
this is great.
I'm getting content show
up on my phone for free,
I don't even have
to touch the phone.
And even I might be able
to earn mobile top ups,
just by simply running
an app on my phone.
This is a really big
value proposition for
people in rural India.
And from the content
providers perspective,
I think this is what's
perhaps most exciting,
they have a way of reaching
a population which they didn't
have a way to reach before.
And another nice advantage is
that they can track how many
times has this
file been watched,
how many times has
it been transferred.
And this enables opportunities
like advertising which is
important for
someone like an NGO.
And then the last opportunity
like I mentioned is,
if they're willing to put in
a little bit of money for
mobile top ups, they can cause
viral spread of some of these
content that they
want to distribute.
So that's actually
all I was gonna say.
I'm really excited for
the panel discussion at the end.
Thank you very much.